i'm on a bike ride in my neighborhood
right now
and i'm seeing some pretty beautiful
clouds
[Music]
these are cumulus clouds when you're
outside on a bright sunny day
you might see hundreds of them like all
clouds they're formed when water vapor
in our atmosphere
sticks to tiny particles of dust and
salt and pollution
floating around in the sky called
aerosols
when water vapor hits an aerosol it
transforms into water droplets or ice
crystals
and when enough of those come together
they form clouds
every cloud is packed with information
and knowing a bit about them can help
you tell the difference between a cloud
that'll disappear in a few minutes
and one that could ruin your picnic
to really know what's going on in a
cloud you have to go right inside it
that's what atmospheric scientists do
i use satellite data aircraft data and
even sometimes
weather balloon data to understand these
processes
associated with clouds and
precipitations that's dr myra oyola
she's an atmospheric scientist who works
at nasa's jet propulsion lab
she's also very good at identifying
clouds like those cumulus ones
cumulus means heap in latin and you can
kind of see why
they look like big heaps of cotton i saw
a bunch when i was on a bike ride in
august
these clouds are normally present when
we have fair weather or good weather so
it's a good day to go outside and play
cumulus are one of the 10 most common
cloud types
which scientists started defining all
the way back in 1802
there's also stratus which means layer
they cover the sky like a blanket
they vary in color so you can see some
that they're
all whiter but they can be grayish and
they are normally associated with what
we call
fair weather our friend anna in michigan
spotted some of those
the weather today is nice and warm
cirrus which means curl look like wisps
of hair
high in the sky my co-worker agnes found
those above lake michigan in chicago
cirrus clouds because they're so high
they're very cold
they're mostly ice very tiny particles
of ice
and they're short-lived and there's
nimbus which means rain
they're normally seen during a
thunderstorm along thunder and lining
these four basic cloud shapes combined
with how high they are in the sky
create the most common clouds like zero
stratus clouds
which exist above 7 000 meters they're
kind of like pink sheets that spread
across the sky
these clouds are interesting because
they tend to be useful
to do weather forecasting in in the
sense that they can tell you
if there's precipitation or snow storm
coming within 12 to 24 hours
altostratus and autocumulus clouds hover
a bit lower between 2 000 and 7
000 meters they often form a sheet like
these fluffy autocumulus ones
vox producer laura saw in maine if you
see them
in the morning this is a tip for weather
forecasting
what it means is that you need to be
prepared because they are normally
produced ahead of thunderstorms
altostratus are less puffy
more like one big blanket they normally
thicken
into being more type of rain bearing
clouds like
nimbus stratus if you see a low dark
gray blanket of clouds
you're probably looking at nimbo stratus
and it's probably already raining
like it was the other day in my backyard
really coming down out here
rain often comes from cumulonimbus
clouds too
they tower from close to the ground to
really high in the sky
they're not going to be your classical
white puffy clouds they're probably
going to be
darker and grayish they're very distinct
and very easy
to identify
when you look at this chart it seems
pretty simple to tell the difference
between these clouds
but in reality it can get a little
tricky for example
look at this photo my friend jess took
while canoeing these are definitely
cumulus and serous clouds
we know that cumulus are associated with
fair weather
however in this particular case i can
probably tell that there was a storm
before the picture was taken for the
most part
storms tend to expand all over the
atmosphere
so you have impacts of the storm really
high up and cirrus clouds tend to
be really high up in the atmosphere
during sunrise or sunset it's pretty
common to see a colorful mix of clouds
in the sky
it's very specific in the sunset because
you obviously have a very
sharp change in temperature going on at
the time
[Music]
those 10 clouds we just talked about
make up nearly all the clouds in the
world
but what about the ones that don't fit
on this chart like here
on top of mount fuji in japan mountain
ranges and other high obstructions
disrupt the normal flow of air as air
moves over the mountains
sinking air warms and rising air cools
which creates these lenticular clouds
they look like fluffy ufos
extreme weather can bring unusual clouds
all over the world
imagine you're sitting outside and you
start to see these bumpy baggy clouds
roll in
they're called momentous clouds and they
usually come along with thunder
lightning and rain
or mostly composed of ice basically the
ice falls
and you have this pouches extending
sometimes
hundreds of miles in any direction ice
crystals help create these weird clouds
too
called fall streak holes scientists
think they're created when ice crystals
in a cloud form
really quickly and then either evaporate
or sink to the ground
so they leave this big hole around the
center of the cloud
some clouds don't even come from nature
these are called contrails which just
means condensation trails
they're made of water vapor from a
plane's exhaust and mimic nature's wispy
cirrus clouds
meaning they're high up and they
disappear really quickly
[Music]
because clouds are above us we tend not
to give them a second thought
but they are super important because
they not only regulate temperature on
the planet
but they're also the primary drivers of
rain and precipitation which we need
to live for us observers on the ground
it takes practice to identify clouds
the tip is to have a cloud chart with a
cloud chart it's very easy to at least
distinguish the clouds that are
at the bottom and the clouds that you
normally tend to see at the top
the clouds are on the middle layers are
probably the most tricky ones
there are lots of communities out there
for cloud watchers like the cloud
appreciation society which accepts
submissions of clouds from all over the
world and adds them to photo galleries
online
if you're ever stumped by a cloud it
might help to look at it from above
the national oceanic and atmospheric
administration has a near
real-time satellite view of clouds that
you can access online
when you combine all these tools
together you can start making
predictions about your day
just based on the clouds above you i
think that those clouds mean that it
will be nice for the next couple of
hours
those big white wispy clouds up there
mean that it's gonna be nice
the cloud chart we made for this video
was super helpful when i was first
learning how to identify clouds
especially when it came to telling the
difference between the basic ones like
cirrus and stratus and cumulus to
download and print out your own cloud
chart
like the one we use in the video get
permission from your parent or guardian
to go to the link below
or have them do it for you happy cloud
hunting
you